der wind ist da die wellen gut so wie
meistens in byron bay
ein tag auf dem wasser easy going
leben auf der leichten seite des lebens
was morgen ist zurück am strand endlich
nach langer pandemie pause bietet er
wieder surfkurse an die zeit ist reif
mehr als zwei jahre waren australiens
grenzen dicht der tourismus komplett am
boden und wer wie gestern von lebt auch
hier ging nichts mehr ich musste mir
einen job suchen also einen richtigen
nach 23 jahren spaß hier als surflehrer
ich habe brennholz gestartet jede arbeit
an von irgendwas mussten wir unser essen
kämpfen es war eine verrückte
nicht für alle ist die vorbei job weg
haus weg alles weg byron bay straßen
sind voll von menschen die das erlebt
haben und noch erleben die jetzt auf die
kommunale hilfs küche angewiesen sind wo
es kostenlos was zu essen gibt drinnen
kochen freiwillige für immer mehr
bedürftige bedürftig nach essen und mehr
wir versuchen ihnen ein lächeln zu
schenken damit der tag etwas leichter
wird es ist einfach hart was manche
leute zu ertragen haben
lohnend lebt seit langem hier liegt gut
von seiner rente er weiß dass es vielen
anderen nicht so geht denn bei rennpace
entwicklung ist paradox
viele sehr reiche leute sind nach byron
bay gezogen es ist schön hier gerade im
coebad locker und war das attraktiv die
immobilienpreise sind im vergangenen
jahr um 70 prozent gestiegen und teuer
war es vorher schon damit sind alle raus
die hier im restaurant hotel café
arbeiten die können sich das niemals
leisten
in der pandemie sind viele hinten
runtergefallen die nie damit gerechnet
haben tourismus 0 arbeitsplatz weg
nieten rauf das war's byron bay hat nach
den metropolen sydney und melbourne die
höchste obdachlosen quote australiens
sie lassen sich nicht gern filmen wenn
sie essen holen oder kostenlos
wäschewaschen unten sein ist nicht
leicht
hat noch einen job arbeitet in einem
supermarkt aber die waren die er dort
ins regal räumt kann er sich selbst kaum
leisten das nötigste holte deshalb hier
ich habe erbsen etwas salat brot müsli
riegel
ich nehme aber nur was ich brauche nicht
zu viel mit für andere leute auch noch
verstärkt
page und viele jobs gehabt mehr verdient
gut gewohnt so eng wie jetzt weiß nie
als er uns am abend sein zuhause zeigt
wird klar was das heißt am rande eines
campingplatzes hatte einen ausrangierten
transporter gemietet seit mehr als einem
jahr lebt er hier und zahlt dafür
umgerechnet 120 euro pro woche
byron bay geht das nicht billiger
findest du hier jedenfalls nicht
und wenigstens habe ich ja noch etwas
privatsphäre
und eine richtige wohnung oder zumindest
ein zimmer
unmöglich da findest du und wenn dann
zahlst du hunderte kommt für mich gar
nicht infrage ich schätze du brauchst
mindestens 300 euro pro woche
der abend endet früher pete mit einer
mahlzeit aus der hilfs küche
mit klagt nicht andere seien schlechter
dran sagt er
danach gibt es nicht mehr viel zu tun
außer sich hinzulegen und auf morgen zu
warten vielleicht auf bessere zeiten
alles geht in byron bay wenn man geld
hat
10.000 einwohner aber zigmal mehr
touristen von denen nicht wenige hängen
bleiben
das städtchen ist ein magnet für reiche
schöne hippe die corona und andere
krisen aussitzen können unter der
australischen sonne
die pandemie die so vieles lahmlegte hat
byron bay für sie zum perfekten platz
gemacht
und ausgelöst was der bürgermeister
es gab einen massiven strom raus aus den
städten zu uns das setzte den
wohnungsmarkt unter druck heute landeten
auf der straße mit diesen enormen
kaufpreisen mieten früher galt hast du
einen job dann ist alles okay damit
bezahlst du dein haus kein problem wenn
du jetzt einen normalen job hast bringt
ihr das vielleicht nichts es sei denn du
verdienst wirklich viel
micaela kommt von der arbeit und geht
dort hin eine schicht im café liegt
hinter ihr und eine schicht im imbiss
vor ihr zwei jobs nacheinander ein
voller tag bringt etwa 140 euro und
stress
ich war fünf minuten zu spät aber okay
dafür bleibe ich etwas länger
um die jobs muss sie kämpfen um jede
einzelne schicht für arbeitgeber sind
mehrere aushilfen günstiger als eine
feste stelle micaela tut was sie kann
und das reicht dann genau dafür ihr
kleiner bus steht auf einem parkplatz am
stadtrand hier schläft sie
auch mit den zwei jobs kann ich mir hier
nicht mehr leisten dann müsste die
arbeit besser bezahlt werden aber für
diese jobs wird in bayern geben relativ
schlecht bezahlt eine richtige wohnung
das ist so nicht drin
es läuft etwas schräg in byron bay das
sich auf die rückkehr der touristen
freut aber für menschen die im tourismus
arbeiten nicht mehr bezahlbar ist das
leben ist irgendwie upside down in down
under